greece is this the first seen the first
chapter of a few chapters we're going to
see across europe and that's the
opposition to the european union I think
it is its tipping point I mean it's been
coming for a long time right we've been
waiting for it because there's been so
much dissatisfaction on the streets
across the periphery in France and even
some of the core states with what has
been crippling austerity and what has
but I mean look we talked 2014 was the
land of pacetti and not in the United
States I mean we bought it we didn't
read it but we bought it but in Europe
you actually lived it right i mean
that's why this guy became as well known
as you did and it's precisely because
you have such crippling youth
unemployment you have ever everywhere
under 30 thinking they have no no choice
no chance in these countries and in
greece the people came out the
birthplace of democracy and they decided
to vote in an astonishing factor for a
party that would have been considered
completely beyond the pails of Greek
democracy in Greek party politics even a
few years ago and we sit here we talk
about anti-european sentiment and often
we talk about the economics we talk
about the markets you speak to
businesses every day about political
risk how concerned are they about the
rise of anti-european sentiment I think
they're concerned about Europe it's not
just about the rise of anti-european
sentiment it's about you know radical
Islam in the region it's about lack of
willingness of the Germans to lead in
collaboration of cooperation with anyone
else it's about the Brits being
completely at the margins of this debate
which is a misfortune for everyone it's
about France also not leading with
Germany and it's about every
geopolitical issue in the world that
affects the Europeans so much worse it
affects the United States to the Chinese
to Japan so Europe really AM if you're
talking to CEOs right now fortune 100
CEO it is volatility oil prices and
concerns about Europe puts absolute
leading church Greece and Greek politics
an example of what is going out on a
square in Europe when you look at
tsipras the big question yesterday
whether this guy was a new Chavez
whether he was the more
business-friendly socialist side of
things where does he sit on the spectrum
in I think there's a question he
certainly is going to be much more
moderate as an individual
now that he's governing and you've seen
that very clearly with his we you know
leaving NATO was I don't have said it
but it's not on the agenda right now and
we still want to be a part of the euro
and we want to negotiate we're not going
to default but you know it's very it's
one thing for him to say that it's
another for all of his ministers for his
new Minister of Finance to have the same
sort of temperance when none of these
people have been in governance before
they're in coalition with the
independent Greeks who haven't been in
government before and they've got some
hefty promises that they need to make
good on and when you see the reaction
from people like Merkel and her
government from christine lagarde and
the IMF and others you realize that the
chasm between where serezha is have and
no one was congratulating serezha on
their win except for Putin basically
yesterday right so I mean they like
Merkel caught up this morning about 20
minutes ago I did I didn't see that and
what did she say she said
congratulations good for her that's a
great responsibility that's just like
Obama deciding this and you know sort of
carry over to France like a week late
right i mean you know the sentiment
shows when you don't get it done
immediately and that's the point right i
mean it's not better late than never
it's actually sometimes better never
than late absolutely